what if you lived in the 1500s and you
knew there was a guy named Sir Geoffrey
Bezos and Suri lon and you knew they
were building what they were going to
call mate flowers and these May flowers
were going to be able to take people to
new worlds how would you prepare the
people who are gonna ride in those boats
so they could survive and thrive on the
other end within 20 years we believe
somebody is going to step off of a
spaceship onto the surface of a world
and that that person is going to go
there to stay and we want that person to
be
[Music]
[Music]
when you see this what do I say I think
I wish I had done that this is Rick
Tomlinson a self-described space
activist one of Congress's go-to guys
for space related matters he recently
put on the new worlds conference an
event for the people who he believes
will be the next generation
pioneers what we're doing is an
experiment at the core of what we're
doing is a serious discussion on the
technologies the engineering policies
things like that that we're going to
need to settle space and then we're
wrapping that in a larger cultural
overlay that includes art and music and
philosophy it's not about the machines
it's not about the engineering it's
about the people
how you doing man what do you got going
on man well just uh showing a really
smart people have been having serious
conversations about colonizing space for
a long time it all started with this guy
named Gerard Kay O'Neill who wrote a
landmark book called the high frontier
that was the book that changed
everything because dr. O'Neill said in
that book you don't have to be NASA to
be involved in space he said you could
go out into space use the principles of
free enterprise harvest the resources of
space and create a new frontier you can
do it and he didn't just write a book
about it and then go you know I wrote
the book he quickly formed an
organization and he started having
conferences to bring people together to
share that dream and inspire each other
as a group when it comes to this
conference I want to create a vision in
people's minds of a credible future in
which they can live out their hopes
their dreams their desires if you open
the frontier if it becomes all about
possibility an infinite array of
possible futures that we get to choose
in some ways New Worlds is like your
average conference
you got your keynote addresses your
expert panels your networking events but
there are two things that make new
worlds really unique the first is a sort
of weird science rave which we'll come
back to in a second is an emphasis on
kids so just don't look in the camera
okay so I'm first Whitney and I love
doing like sorts of programming things
and I started programming a couple years
ago and I got a Raspberry Pi it's just a
little computer the premise of the
Institute is that within 20 years the
first human beings are going to be
stepping on the Moon or Mars or into a
colony in space with the intention of
living there so if you're looking at a
20 year window these kids are going to
be the people doing it but what I did
here in this presentation I basically
just created a movie so what I did is I
built this 3d model in Minecraft so it's
showing a 3d model of the space station
or thing that we and I'm going to call
it a free space colony notice status
these two right here are your apartment
buildings here's the farm we use
hydroponics with gel and we get the
fertilizer which we make on earth and
just have it delivered there first the
main focus what for me was the
artificial gravity and transportation do
the different floors from the space
station and that's just a little rocket
that will go off with supplies and come
back and that's basically the
agriculture area where you know you're
growing trees and plants and crops and
food and stuff do you really get this
conference you could have the next
Magellan or Columbus or Neil Armstrong
or is that two grand no not at all but I
would rather have
the first person whose name you don't
remember that built a cabin and started
a farm okay
the ones who don't get named otherwise
who actually builds the communities we
call them settlement right and they
could be here
[Music]
to prepare for a space-themed show we
get the proper props we brought a lot of
fans that look like fire and start like
fans of stars on it and stuff and we're
using our LED hoops okay so now on to
the rave that I told you about yes those
are Tesla coils shoot an electricity at
dancers in a cage
and yes that is Rick getting his groove
on but it's not just that he loves
dancing in giant Tesla coils he's
actually got a pretty interesting reason
for the concert what we're talking about
here is not just technology and
engineering we're talking about a
creative media culture all right it has
to be a culture that celebrates the
future has to be a culture that
celebrates that we're taking on
impossible or to make you pause every
major cultural movement in history has
said it has had its tribal dances has
had its celebration has had its ability
to just let its hair down and go crazy
right so you dance around the fire at
night after you've fought dragons during
the day
[Music]
so I get it all this new world stuff
sounds a little bit crazy but maybe
they're onto something
I'm sure jobs and Wozniak looked a
little bit crazy building computers in
their garage could rip in these kids and
these dancers be people who end up
changing the world it only takes a few
people to change the future you know
there were only a few people on those
first ships that came to the new worlds
over here there are only a few people
that ever change anything it's it's
never the mass that changes the future
it's always a small group of people that
identifies and trailblazers new ideas
and philosophies and new approaches to
tomorrow what if in the future a child
could grow up in a world and look up at
the sky and see these little dots of
light going out and be a part of a
civilization whose goal is to expand
life to worlds that are now dead what I
want to see is humanity beginning to
reach the capabilities and possibilities
that we all know in our
that's powerful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you